so you know I I live in a different
world than a lot of you who are probably
watching this because many of the people
have an action watch this are very
heavily into the web 2.0 internet
business
I actually am part of the old world of
business right I uh
I deal in the wine and liquor business
and deal with a lot of old-school
advertisers and business people
executives and so I get my feet oh sure
of spending a lot of time with people in
that 40 and over demo and a lot of the
talk right now is about how this
transparent market things like Twitter
and quick and Facebook and Ustream are
taking away our privacy and changing the
game and what I want to talk about today
is how technology has finally been like
the steel chair that goodness needed to
destroy and beat badness and here's what
I want to get to in a world that's
changing so quickly the quick technology
for example that I dealt with over to
this last weekend is is mind boggling in
a world that's changing so quickly where
everything is transparent where
everything you do is captured with
Flickr and YouTube and Twitter and quick
and kite and things of that nature where
every part of your movement is captured
what's going to happen is that people
that are good that are awesome
that come from the heart are going to
win and people that are bad that have
horrible intentions are going to lose
understand this anything you do is going
to be known you're not gonna be able to
have multiple personalities one for the
chicks one for business one for this ah
it's over you are who you are now in
this world and you need to understand
that very quickly your personal brand
now is completely exposed to the world
24/7 everybody my friends is now the
media and because of this the media is
the great equalizer and everything you
do will be exposed and unraveled so try
to think very hard what you want to be
to the world